without question old towel is the oldest
wealthiest and greatest city in Westeros
though King's Landing is more populous
and arguably more powerful the city
straddles the mouth of the honey wine
river and the bounty of the entire rich
flows beneath it stripped stone bridges
to ports that are renowned throughout
the world
thus we didn't speak more of more
interesting is the history of the city
for none can say when it was founded
many centuries ago a few bold maesters
sought out the children of the forest
who claimed that men have lived at the
mouth of the honey wine since the dawn
age nonsense
maester Jellico proved that the city
began as a trading post where ships from
Valyria old geese and the Summer Isles
put in to replenish their provisions or
make repairs
hence the most famous feature of the
city the high tower raised even before
the city wolves as a beacon through the
fog covered waters originally built a
wood understanding a mere 50 feet above
the ancient fortress of his foundation
it is our thick stone and rises even
taller than the wall I was born and
raised in Old Town could tell the time
of day by where shadow falls but no Mesa
can tell why even in our oldest records
the island on which it stands is called
battle Isle
what battle was fought there and when as
for the ancient fortress that forms the
towers base its walls and interiors are
all of solid black stone with no hints
of joins or mortar and no chisel marks
of any kind we know it predates the
tower itself by thousands of years but
who built it how and against what the
maesters who have studied it declared it
to be a Valyrian construction akin to
dragon stone and the black walls of
volantis as is well known the
Dragonlords of Bolivia could turn stone
to liquid with dragon flame to shape as
they wished didn't one arch master link
the fortress to the vanished maze makers
of Laura and another master to the
legendary Deep Ones who inhabited the
Iron Islands before the Ironborn both
marginal opinions without common support
but of more importance than the origin
of the tower is the family to which it
gave his name house Hightower the
ancient ruling family of old town known
for their prudence and love of peace and
pieces of gold during the Age of Heroes
when Lyman Hightower saw the Gardiner
Kings conquering the reach he didn't
meet them on the battlefield but in the
godswood he bound his house to theirs by
marriage and transformed house Hightower
from wealthy but relatively minor kings
to the greatest Lords of the rich
thanks to Lord Lyman's foresight
Highgarden has always defended Old Town
allowing the high towers to focus on
higher pursuits such as learning and
trade on that we agree
when the Andals invaded Westeros Lord
Dorian Hightower told his wife of 20
years that wars are bad for trade and to
make his point traded her free young and
old princess when Aegon the Conqueror
was earning his name house Hightower
traded its loyalty to the gardener's for
his confirmation of their rights
welcoming him with open arms and open
gates House Hightower bent for knee to
Aegon to spare the city from his dragons
I would think such insinuations and
insults beneath even you kybun and then
again mockery of one's betters is the
trade of fools
I wouldn't know perhaps if I'd studied
at the Citadel as long as you grand
maester the Citadel is the greatest seat
of learning in the known world without
it and a mace is it trains Westeros
would be a land of superstition and
ignorance like the ignorance the tribes
the Citadel's own birth even without
records we have more than enough reason
to believe that the Citadel began as a
court of scholars and priests assembled
by a second son of House height Allah
when he died his elder brother raised
the Citadel so that wise man would
always have a home in Westeros and could
continue the inquiries and debates that
had given such joy to his younger
brother his little brother's pets as
legend has it he called them and so the
Masters have remained only their masters
now they serve every Lord with a castle
for a fee of course
whilst the Citadel serves its own
importance every word you speak merely
validates your own expulsion from our
ranks knowledge is validation enough I
assumed the world's greatest minds would
agree and perhaps they would if I'd met
them Old Town is a City for old men and
old beliefs but the world is changing no
matter how high the tower the clouds
will not hold it up if the ground shifts
beneath it
[Music]